ariana grande is switching her position
from fiance
to white
[Music]
earlier this month et confirmed that the
singer officially tied the knot with
luxury realtor
dalton gomez and now ari is sharing the
pics to prove it
it was like so crazy on wednesday the 27
year old singer posted these stunning
wedding photos to instagram
showcasing her custom lilly white silk
gown designed by vera wang
completing the look with pearl and
diamond earrings matching her engagement
ring
i'm happy life is good according to
vogue ariana's wedding look was inspired
by audrey hepburn's character joe
stockton and funny face
specifically the bubble veil that had a
satin bow on top finale of the
collection
wedding day they're beautiful ariana
also shared photos of the gorgeous
decorations where the couple said i do
she also posted a snapshot of the
newlyweds sharing a kiss
captioning the post with their wedding
date 5 15
21 i feel your love every day the small
and intimate ceremony took place in
montecito california with less than 20
people in attendance
which according to vogue included her
mom and dad who gave her away
and her rescue dog toulouse who was also
a part of their special day
a source previously told et the couple
wanted the ceremony to be private and
took precautions to make sure that
happened
in the past ariana has shied away from
being public with her relationships
which she opened up about tet in 2016.
i'm very sharing and very open
and then i'll like be asked about it by
like you and i'll be really nervous and
like weird but i'm
getting there i'm working on that part
but like i think that
me being open with my fans and my
supporters is like a
very important thing because like it's
like
life you know what i mean privacy aside
the source also adds that ariana and
dalton are ecstatic about their marriage
and looking forward to their future
together
the couple first sparked dating rumors
last february and in may they made their
first public appearance together in
ariana's music video with justin bieber
for stuck with you later dalton proved
he's there for ari rain or shine
literally when he helps the singer out
in this hilarious video
it'll be raining all summer but we'll
surely be dancing as it does
the pair got engaged in december after
nine months of dating
dalton popped the question with this
unique diamond and pearl ring
many fans suspect the pearl is part of a
family heirloom
from a thai pin that belonged to her
late grandfather
[Music]
congrats to the couple on their stunning
wedding day